anouilh et les bois l'exploitation de
production bio de plants de légumes et
d'aromatiques participe depuis plusieurs
années à l'opération de ferme en ferme
pour philippe le lam l'agriculteur c'est
un moment privilégié pour expliquer sa
démarche
là c'est de pouvoir poser mes outils et
de leur consacrer du temps pour leur
expliquer ce que je fais comment je le
fais et partager un peu mon expérience
de producteur vous qui avez l'habitude
ils passent combien de personnes amis
alors sur un week-end c'est plus de 200
personnes
et l'année dernière on était à 2 160
visiteurs si certains viennent juste
pour découvrir certains reviennent pour
acheter des produits dans lesquels ils
se retrouvent et seront bio et puis donc
différentes espèces nous on veut variée
notre collection de légumes et à propos
du godet vous savez quelque chose a
priori je crois qu'ils sont potables
cette année les visiteurs ont sûrement
été attiré par la découverte de
l'atelier des pis en effet le fils de
philippe quilliam a décidé de se lancer
dans cette activité avec la même
exigence éthique
dès l'an prochain il doit finaliser son
installation dans un séchoir jeu mais à
peu près 25 kg
de poivrons de poivrons frais et j'en
sors 3 kg 50 c'est vraiment super
d'avoir des opérations comme ça dans
dans la région même au niveau national
ne serait ce que pour nous ça va
permettre de faire connaître mon
activité
voilà de discuter avec les personnes
voilà ça c'est vraiment un moment très
très important très très chouette aussi
de la lyre ne serait-ce que les visites
dit fière de voir les personnes
intéressées poser des questions ça c'est
aussi voilà c'est motivant kilian aura
en effet expliqué tout le week-end
comment avec les productions bio qu'il
va développer
il va étendre sa gamme d'épi ce fait en
berry